нехай сама
радіо студія нікого з тварин у зоні ато
навіть просто апаратура
китайську продавати просто не знайде
буксу буквально антена солдат Олександр
безсонів та його помічений кит марсик на
gmail та годинник на фронті кожного дня
навпаки zen кроку боку фронту
он і продавав і в ефір новими та музику
з гриву чотири українські телеканали
навіть панелі ловиться риба крут цієї
антенну
млинці з бубном танцювати і що зараз
зло вийти радіостанції це одна якось
української лову ціни в суди
сепарський танк їжа десятка тепер
лександр продовжу свою інформативну
провину в жеу клич новачків йому радіо
міноборони
ванною свої тільки місяць і пошуковому
шведку тут ст і очі порожні також кілька
регулярних програм на гуліна армія
фактом роблячи на кравченку зоні бойових
дій з українських ризикових на заміну
10 кореспондентові в техніці цивільні
вся кава в силу вимагає зарплату виду
Міноборони головний редактор я на холодно
майор алимова на case you wonna навик
російської і кожен тут творча дисципліна
ризиковий курс панди geo 3 місце
міністерство оборони абсолютно ла ямуту
на основі що він і
і нам їх у цьому говорити про це про ціну
говорити ми відкриття абсолютно та все
час травня моста такими данина чифом для
заворот його стягнув для наших весь кого
щоб ми чол та їх не проблема це
допомагало їм їх виріжуть весь кого радіо я
дещо змії україни в умовах провини
Донбасі cool та на мій забезпеченому
доступу на відшибі до фронту навряд година
чоловікові сюди 3 молодість а принципі
називаєш дуету об'єктивною
журналістикою шановний експерт Юрій Лу
канал про т і пропагандистським весь кого
радіо навряд чи стани
але ви на вигляд по видному ти уват і
бензин з повтору впізнавати і призначаєш і
підлозі на but i'm a ванної новини
чип чипові небудь якісь
а брехня так ось це кейдж а в офісі
плані попросимо води над тим, що ви
роботи такі контент давид по видно було
просто вами акценти щоб убити і
зрозуміло захищений воюю чому він його
яєчка у нього
Олександр особливий 100 знаючи на знижки
важливо для лиття радіо на фронті
українська армія ф.м. буде кілька прем'єр
за крима та його програма українською
техно 90-х